alors on se souvient tous des événements
du printemps 2012 au québec
rappelez-vous le gouvernement de madame
marois avait commandé un rapport
serge ménard ancien ministre du parti
québécois ancien député du bloc était à
la tête de ce groupe de travail donc un
des audiences et des témoignages etc
certains ont refusé d'aller s'y
présenter c'est le cas du syndicat du
policier c'est le cas aussi de certains
groupes de jeunes qui trouvent l
exercice passé équilibré bref rapport
qui a été rendu public hier soir 430
pages rapport très sévère envers le
gouvernement charest
on lui reproche de ne pas avoir négocié
assez rapidement avec les étudiants
d'une part et on reproche beaucoup
beaucoup à la police sûreté du québec
aussi la police de montréal ces
techniques d'intervention j'ai rencontré
ian lafrenière ya quelques minutes
il ya la première bonsoir bonsoir voila
il ya énormément de recommandation dans
ce rapport ménard qui touche la police
de montréal faire vous êtes allés devant
la commission votre chef est taillée sur
la présence du chef plus une présence de
plusieurs cartes qui étaient vraiment
impliqué ou au milieu de toutes ces
manifestations alors et on se bat défilé
on était présent très important
d'expliquer le travail des policiers
mais très fier du travail de nos
policiers pendant les manifestations ont
des leçons à vendre oui comme tout le
monde on est une organisation apprenante
mais on n'avait aucune ou qu'un malaise
être présent et expliquer comment les
policiers de travailler j'avais bien
travaillé ce parce que le ya énormément
de recommanderont pas toutes les passes
et une à une mais il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de recommandations qui vous
concerne la police de montréal entre
autres les opérations d'encerclement ont
dit vous en avais trop fait et c'était
trop long quand vous avez en cirque les
ai mises en arrestation des gens
l'utilisation du poivre de cayenne ont
dit on devrait plus faire ça les saisons
des chevaux de la cavalerie est ce qu'on
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec un
certain nombre de recommandations qu'on
vous fait mais premièrement c'est un
rapport volumineux 450 pages dans leur
suivi un schéma ou deux ans
dans vos dix ans qu'on en a pris
connaissance je comprenais tout le
rapport qu'on s'est vraiment de quelle
façon volume été réalisés mais les
points importants pour nous sur 28
recommandations des 18 qui touche
l'espère m ou du service de police jeudi
la police et de ce nombre est au moins
la moitié qui ont déjà été plantés
quels changements déjà des changements
qu'on a fait tuer exemple les
manifestations aux charmantes aussi nous
dit que des manifestations 1 et la
manifestation 700 on n'est pas évolué
mais certains mandats on a décidé de
déplacer une autre femme marché nos
policiers en parallèle à ces
manifestations
pourquoi je suis en contact les
manifestants ils seront deux forces qui
sait qu'ils se confrontent mais vraiment
des politiques qui marchent à
l'impulsion le fait par des
manifestations et aussi le fait les jo
nous écouter mais certainement de on
sait pas quand la manifestation est
illégal fait une annonce et peu audible
on comprend pas ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qu'on a fait à ce moment-là
implication des médias sociaux avec
twitter on rejoignait les gens dans
votre station
c'est illégal qui t on aussi racheter
des signaux sonar dans la fois les
crises qu'on va faire on va utiliser la
sirène c'est le moment où je vous parle
il avait chargement puis je voudrais un
buzz en passant des services de police
que vicky le plus de nos prestations de
réguler ans à deux ans on s'est adapté
ont évolué est ce que des changements
qu'on va faire sauter sera pas là et
schémas des choses qui vont toucher on
va regarder vous et regardez comme
services de police comme organisation
apprenante on va s'améliorer
on n'est pas les seuls à essayer les
nôtres sommes le seul point je vais vous
emmener ce soir et notre temps on peut
regarder ce qu'ils on peut faire de
mieux
on a même chuté à concevoir qu'on était
les seuls visés dans tout ce conflit la
dette qu'on aurait pu parler un peu plus
ses étudiants on n'est pas tu as regardé
comme organisation précise regarder ce
qu'on peut faire de mieux on est puni
pour les civils sont visés notent
surtout avec sa maquette de
deux balances ce rapport là où finale
jeudi qu'une partie qui nous appartient
chacun a donc vont faire le même
exercice qui ont sauvegardé preuve de
cayenne on a vu ces images la fameuse
samedi ou sur une terrasse rue saint
denis là on espère juge joyeusement
est ce que ça vous dit oui c'est vrai on
est très utilisé c'était un caprice il
faut 13 juin corps et ed plainte en
déontologie et des prétendus scène qui
sort doucement à ce moment là des
sanctions envers ces polices il une
session d armes et et rosaire juste leur
appui sans tomber dans le détail quand
on utilise un an maintenant interdisent
à ckoi vu les gens pensent et pour
chemin faire mal au genou c'est pour
rester no minimum du ca sion de la force
physique
au lieu d'aller sur la période et
multiplicateur de force aussi vous
rappeler les bombes qu'ils étaient
lancés dans les airs qui cause d'un
survival a regardé puis je vous dis pas
qu'on va on va qui et c'est ça notre but
ce n'est pas allé dans une confrontation
physique si on enlève toutes les armes
intermédiaires et qu'on demandait le
principal et dans un corps à corps je
pense que c'est ce que vous voulez voir
comme société et elle sera encore plus
violent par contre un point qu'en
terminant et on va terminer là dessus ça
fait beaucoup les manchettes
l'utilisation des balles de plastique on
dit que les policiers visent mal que
certains sont mal entraînés
il ya eu des incidents aussi à des
allégations au sujet d'un citoyen sur un
oeil en particulier qu'elles sont c'est
à ce moment là on parle de ne sait même
pas un projections qui étaient tirés le
citoyen auquel fait référence ce qui est
allégué c'est qu'on a lorsqu'on a lancé
une grenade son éclat au niveau de
l'oeil
c'est une enquête qui est même des
rapports notes qui ont été sorties
nocturnes
moi je termine en vous disant écoutez on
va regarder que ça aussi des choses
qu'on peut faire de mieux c'est évident
que mon appréhension aussi présenté
devant comme si on voulait vraiment nous
ont démontré le travail de policier ça
fait une centaine d'années qu'on veut ce
travail l'avons conçu d'apprendre on
continue de s'améliorer mais ai pas dit
que tout ce que la donne pourrait
changer de jour là mais chez nous il ya
des techniques nos points hier soir on
était sur la rue on avait plusieurs
centaines de procès sur la vue pour
encadrer on salue les scissions
réellement rien que mes citoyens
policiers j'ai eu beaucoup de bons
commentaires de part et d'autre les
jantes elle voulait célébrer ils l'ont
fait sans casse noisette un message fort
sur leur applique aux montréalais c'est
possible mais c'est amuser sans tout
casser
il ya la fresnière merci on en apprendra
ailleurs il ya d'autres moments parce
que beaucoup beaucoup de com c'est pas
comme n'est plus vraiment merci ans à
vous